[Musique]
mais c'est un rêve quand on me demande
quand on me parle des cheveux longs
d'abord je commence par dire que je n'ai
rien contre les garçons qui porte les
cheveux longs je vois pas pourquoi je
trouve que vous ressemblez la fois
achoppé à françoise sagan je pense que
c'est une question de l'époque
et quand on me demande de qui ils sont
et qu'on me donne une définition pour
chaque cas j'ai une définition courte
parce que je peux pas passer la journée
en parler et pour vous jeudi un arrêt
c'est un garçon qui a beaucoup de talent
et qui couchait soulevés trop lamarck
caulaincourt parce qu'il disait que
c'est là qu'il y avait le moindre
courant d'air et il était prix de
conservatoire à 12 ans ce que je sais
c'est ce que me disent mes oreilles et
quand j'entends quelque chose en tant
que ce qu'il chantait jolie que les
paroles sont charmantes et quelques fois
drôle et que c'est un vrai musicien ce
qu'il faut à travers moi chercher c'est
pas tellement à compléter mon personnage
à moi mais chercher à découvrir celui
des autres c'est à dire justement des
autres à challans comme vous appeliez et
parce que je crois que justement
justement que quelqu'un réussit on ne
parle plus mais je leur dis pas c'est un
garçon à cheveux longs dit tiens il a du
talent et qui tient en fait en plus il a
les cheveux blancs tandis que les autres
ne voient que le côté physique
c'est ce qui crée justement cette sorte
de divorce entre entre la société et eux
parce que d'un côté comme de l'autre
personne ne cherche à comprendre
l'adversaire eux s'ils ne veulent pas
s'insérer dans cette société
parce qu'elle est pleine de principe et
cette société ne veut pas toujours aller
jusqu'à faut distinguer snobisme est
vraiment volonté de empêcher les guerres
d'empêcher les révoltes ya beaucoup de
ces garçons qui sont sur les quais ou
sur les marches à mon art qui a trois ou
quatre ans aurait pu porter des
pantalons pattes d'éléphant drugstore
par exemple et qui ont maintenant
adopter la parka parce que c'est la mode
mais y en a d'autres qui sont vraiment
sincères mais qui n'ont pas forcément
les cheveux longs vous pensez en tous
les cas c'est une manière de
protestation pour certains pour certains
c'est une manière de protestation oui
j'estime que un garçon qui son père qui
a travaillé toute sa vie pour un salaire
de misère et qui tout à coup réalise qui
va avoir la même vie et qui se révoltent
et qui mène cette vie sur les berges de
la seine c'est très bien parce qu'ils
refusent cette image qu'il a connu celui
qui le fait part par flemme c'est très
mal c'est votre manière d'être
syndicaliste
enfin se disant je je veux mais si vous
voulez jouer considérable beatnik je
voulais dans la décision que je donne
moi la définition c'est à dire faire un
peu fait ce que voudra pas pour moi
c'est pas seulement fait ce que vous
pensez aussi prouver parce que je crois
c'est important de prouver à ceux qui
vous ont plu ou moins cher éviter qu
après tout vous pouvez fait aussi bien
que et peut-être même mieux si vous
aurez la possibilité
moi je n'ai pas si vous voulez la
possibilité de me révolter puisque
depuis le depuis le départ tout le monde
a été très gentil avec moi ça m'ennuie
presque un peu parce que du jour au
lendemain les gens ont trouvé mes
chansons bien
donc j'ai pas eu la possibilité de dire
un de lutte et de les envoyer elles sont
bien les chansons et je crois que le
monde est plein de contradictions et je
vais moi même sorti un petit peu de la
société de toute façon je je pense si
vous voulez que les jeunes sont attirés
par le romantisme qui pourtant s'ils
voulaient au départ est contraire à ce
badges et pourtant pas tellement parce
que il ya d'abord l'opposition avec tous
ces principes qui d'un ajustement raison
à ce badge et ensuite les jeunes quand
ils réfléchissent quand ils commencent à
réfléchir
ils redeviennent l'image de la société
d'avant qu'il critiquait
[Musique]